new favorite tik tok check it out there
is no such thing as a coincidence
the fact that you're watching this video
means you are energetically aligned with
me
and this message your thoughts create
your reality well you already knew that
yeah
you still live a life that you dread
that is because when you visualize your
dream
imagine just getting jump scared while
you're you're jogging and get jump
scared by this [ __ ] dude
and he just keeps going you
unconsciously believe that it is unreal
did he kill her with his eyes what
happened
for real i need to know there she comes
you still live a life that you dread
that is because
it's beautiful oh wonderful thank you
as someone who likes to play games
online you know that solo matchmaking is
one of the worst things
to ever play a gamer sometimes it work
most of the time nah but now there's a
solution for that
called party they make gaming safe fun
and rewarding by pairing you up with the
perfect squad make friends for life
find gamer wife party gives you all in
one matchmaking
voice video hacks chat or free
and you can also earn money by becoming
a party leader
and help other gamers play games in a
safe fun environment download party with
a link in the description use the code
pewdiepie
join for free and get this you'll have a
chance to play with me
i will connect with you for my live
stream this sunday on the amp
fourth of july and we'll play some
minecraft together
it was really fun last time check it out
party it's quick
simple and freely supports gamer safety
check it out
that's it on with the video so we put my
dog in the bathroom and acted like we
left the house
and this is what we saw i keep thinking
this is staged but i also think it
isn't i'm just confused
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
the more i look at it the more oh my god
maybe dogs are like boys from toy story
and they just act like dogs when we're
around this could be proof
dog was like oh sh better close the door
the dog clearly just got scared okay
customer states
oh okay blue light on dash
nice
better just turn that off then you can't
make this [ __ ] up
how much do you think they paid for that
something blew in my dash
help me help me how did they get a
driver license
god if i was to how do you approach that
to the customer and be like yeah we
fixed your problem
you tell them you just char i don't get
it i feel like half of my tick tocks are
just
stuff i want to show marzia and she
loves it
it looks like edgar look how cute he is
hello
my first thought was pewdiepie same bro
i was like that's like my dogs one
younger black one and one older
beige one there's always two pugs always
yeah well if my wife decided we would
have a whole army of them
okay here we go there's a good ship 700
feet high sand dunes 49 square miles of
sand
the sand does not conform to any of the
silica in the valley wow that's crazy
but the most mind-blowing thing about
the sand dunes is what is a core sample
test
and they were drilling down in the very
center of the dune field and when they
got to the bottom of the dunes
700 feet down they hit wood why there's
a covered
forest that's covered by the dunes so
they've carbon 14 dated the wood it's
only 11 000 years old so the dunes are
only
have been there 11 000 years that's
crazy you have a pile of sand
49 square miles 700 feet high
that's been piled up in less than 12 000
years
i had a physicist friend of mine he
called me up all excited one day and he
goes i figured out
how the dunes got there okay what is it
it's the ant people there's
we live and the ant people
are making more room by carving up the
courts
you lost man and people the ant people
listen i figured it out man those
[ __ ] ants oh ants no ants
people okay they live under there my
interest
all right let's hear about the ants
people back door and that's where the
glass is coming from
it's the largest pile of pure glass on
the planet and people we're
we're just brushing a past and people
and people
okay and people is it all right [ __ ]
i don't need to discriminate against ant
people my bad
gonna get cancelled in like 20 years
when they i become old and i become weak
this is all he needs to entertain me at
this point
a cute dog he looks like he got a
facelift he looks so young now
why he became puppy just like that so
cute
don't judge me oh my god another [ __ ]
dog video
god damn it water i will end the video
see how this goes
just a little bit of splash already he
tries his best okay i really thought he
was gonna make it man
hell yeah love going to the hairdresser
so relaxing getting my eyebrows clean as
well
this this this can't be real
but it also makes it so funny if it is
[Laughter]
i want it to be
bro you better not charge this man
that's the most patient man i've ever
seen i mean he can't open his eyes
you're clearly splashing in what is he
gonna do
on this episode of i raised a kitten
quarantine and now i have a cat with
separation anxiety
we are in the shower
that's not how you shower you stupid cat
that's why dogs are better than cats
point proven he was excited seeing
outside
until he saw a big bird flying
[Laughter]
scream for help shame
that is so me oh my [ __ ] god i've
become the person
it's all dog an animal oh my god who's
mr bond
get your nails clipped or perish in the
river below
what will it be mr bond
[Laughter]
everyone is trying to be funny on tech
talk right and most of them are just
aren't when i see an animal
it's just funny yo baba how's the food
tasting
oh this stuff is bursting
oh yeah uh-huh
he's ready
[Applause]
i mean i know it's staged or whatever
but that's beyond the point
i just love how he tries so hard on the
sheesh
he's gonna pop the vein in his neck i
just realized you can't talk while
inhaling through your nose
tv
god damn so
cute dude look at the ending
look at this ending it melts your heart
oh
i love it make me not hate earth and
everyone me okay
nature's fine we can keep nature going
oh my god it's like i liked one video
and tic tacs is like you you like this
[ __ ] you like bad
female golfers this is like okay i mean
i do it's funny but
it just makes me feel like such an
[ __ ] like tick tock has decided you
you like this you're like bad female
cover like no i didn't ask
i didn't ask for it but yes i like it
they never taught us
anything at school they never taught us
any nothing you could use
it was a waste of time maths english
science
when do you ever use we're gonna use
that all right you never taught us how
to change a tire
or to rewire a plug or to contest your
council tax bracket
honestly school didn't teach you
anything
hey miss did you cry when your husband
died
who did that who did that no one's ever
done that
[ __ ] no it's almost definitely done that
[Music]
are you off your [ __ ] wits mate no
[ __ ] way no way
no no god [ __ ] no
that is the worst idea i've ever seen oh
my god
oh why why would you even think of that
what's wrong with paper
get a bidet if you don't want to wipe
with paper get a big day
spray your hands before you give me this
anyway that's enough tick tock for today
hope you
enjoyed smash like subscribe check out
my other ones goodbye
bye bye